outils bourgeois
vous voyez Steve Ross pizza party serait
passé les cotisations sont commises Yael est
un plus sur coulé je veux dire les nazis de l'hospice
j'adore ça j'adore être à Paris nous sommes dans
le dernier divorce ce serait adorable été
plus le  faire la fête et juste envie de se tenir debout
et bien sûr c'est un délice d'être à
Paris il y a des gens du
monde entier et vous entendez du français chinois
quelles que soient toutes sortes de langues mais si
certains d'entre vous veulent se réunir le
meilleur moment pour moi serait sur  le
mercredi 6 sauf pour une tasse de
café vers 10h00 du matin
cela ne vous conviendra peut-être pas auquel
cas je m'excuse mais ce serait le
moment où je serais libre pour
une réunion ou éventuellement l'
après-midi  sur les 6, faites-moi savoir si
vous êtes intéressé en attendant profitez de
Paris comme je profite de Paris